[MUSIC PLAYING]
DONNA MALAYERI: All right,
welcome to Session 303--
Building Solutions
with Serverless
on Kubernetes Engine.
We actually wanted to call
this building solutions
with Cloud Run on GKE,
but for obvious reasons,
we didn't have that
session title until
just now as I'm saying it.
So what we're going
to be talking about
is our new offering,
Cloud Run on GKE,
and how you can take
advantage of it.
I'm Donna Malayeri.
I'm a product manager.
MARK CHMARNY: And
I'm Mark Chmarny.
I'm one of the technical
program managers looking
after serverless, specifically
things on top of Kubernetes.
DONNA MALAYERI: All right, so
let's talk about Kubernetes.
It's really fascinating.
Kubernetes has basically
emerged as the de facto standard
for container orchestration.
It's really picked
up steam, and people
who have been using
other solutions
are finding Kubernetes is
great for their needs, which
is awesome.
And there's a huge ecosystem.
There's a ton of
companies building on it.
There's jobs that are growing.
The stat that I saw was the
jobs are growing 250% month
over month.
And I think the real test
that technology has taken off
is when recruiters ask for
10 years of experience in it.
And of course, Kubernetes has
not been around not even--
there are very few
people who even have
five years' experience in it.
But that's how
entrenched it's become,
people forget how new it is.
MARK CHMARNY: So
the very popularity
that Donna was just
talking about of Kubernetes
is also driving a large number
of use cases-- a growing
number of use cases
that people try to use
Kubernetes to address with.
That means that
today, Kubernetes
is able to do the container
scheduling that it
was able to do at day
one, but it's also
able to do load
balancing and identity
management and authorization
and many other services that
make the operator, the
Kubernetes operator
experience very friendly.
Their work is made simpler.
Kubernetes obfuscates
a lot of the complexity
of the underlining
infrastructure from them
so they don't have to
worry about the VMs
or whatever else is underneath.
And to a large
degree, even better
when you run on top of a
managed Kubernetes service
like GKE, which makes this
whole experience so much better.
So that ubiquity, the fact that
Kubernetes is available pretty
much in every single cloud
service provider today--
it's hard to find one that does
not offer Kubernetes service--
means that developers
are naturally
interested in the service.
But their experience
is not as smooth.
Developers, I believe,
on the end of the day,
they really just
want to write code.
Just give me something
to write code
and make sure that it runs well.
Developing directly
on top of Kubernetes.
So if you're a
developer and you're
writing application in Java,
Go, Python, whatever it may be,
it's possible and people
do it, and there's
a lot of tools around it
that make it possible,
but you have to stitch
those tools just right,
you have to make sure
that they work perfectly.
And there's a lot of toil that's
involved also in this process.
So you have to--
besides just
building the images,
which at this point,
frankly, everybody does,
but there's also exposing that
service to the outside world
or managing traffic.
And also to a large
degree, Kubernetes still
optimized for batch
workloads, which means--
which amongst many other things
means that it scales on CPU.
For modern applications
that you're writing today,
CPU scalability is probably
not the right way to do that.
You're looking for a
low latency of response,
you're looking for ability
to scale up and down,
and all of that is not
directly available to you
as a developer.
So modern stateless
application development
on top of Kubernetes
definitely could get better,
and we'd like to have
Donna tell us about that.
DONNA MALAYERI: All right,
so our solution to this
is Cloud Run.
This is the new product that
we've launched this week,
and we're bringing
serverless to containers.
So what does that mean?
Now serverless is
an interesting term,
because of course it's a
misnomer-- there are obviously
servers involved.
It's also an interesting term
when you talk about a cluster
that you manage yourself.
So what we talk about is
a serverless developer
experience.
If you use the fully hosted
Cloud Run, which is the default
one if you go into the Cloud Run
console and create a service,
it's fully serverless.
There are no clus-- there's
no cluster to manage.
And you only pay
for what you use.
Essentially, we, Google
Cloud, is your operator.
We're managing all of that
underlying infrastructure
for you.
Now, the reality is that
when you have a cloud vendor
as your operator, there
is a lot of assumptions
that we make that may
not suit your needs,
and that's where Kubernetes
comes in and Cloud Run on GKE.
And what this means is if
you use Cloud Run on GKE,
your operators have this
great Kubernetes experience.
You can set up role-based access
control, networking policies,
you can decide what cluster you
want, all that kind of stuff.
But developers are
abstracted from this,
and they have a serverless
developer experience
that can scale up and down.
So Cloud Run on GKE compared
to the fully hosted Cloud Run
gives you a lot
more flexibility.
Of course there's
more to manage,
but if that's what you're
already intending to do,
it can be a great choice.
If you already have GKE, Cloud
Run on GKE is a great option.
So you have more machine
options, you can run on GPUs,
you can access more things
that are currently integrated
with Cloud Run on GKE.
MARK CHMARNY: Thanks.
So Donna has explained kind of
the differences between the two
flavors of Cloud Run.
Cloud Run gives you the
consistent developer experience
regardless where you run it,
whether it's on a managed
service or on Cloud Run on GKE.
But coming back to
the original picture
that we talked about, when
developers use Cloud Run, some
of the things that they had to
do before are still happening.
They're just happening
behind the scene
and happen automatically,
or they're made much easier.
So you continue getting the
very same power of Kubernetes
underneath, but
you're able to benefit
from a lot of automation
that Cloud Run on GKE
delivers to you.
And what that means
is that you don't
have to focus as much on
the manual step, the shaving
the axe, so to speak, over and
over building those images,
there's a way to
integrate other--
exposing the service
to the internet.
And because Cloud Run is
supporting Knative APIs--
and more about that
later, you will
be able to preserve that
same developer experience
whether you run on Cloud Run
on GKE, Cloud Run hosted,
or whether you run on top of
another Knative-compatible
offering, whether
it's on-premise
that you run yourself,
or whether it's consumed
through another provider.
So let's go a little deeper
into some of the benefits
the developer gets from
running Cloud Run on GKE
and what that means to them.
So first of all, I was
talking about automation.
There's one of the
key features that we
talk about with
regards to Cloud Run,
whether it's on GKE or on
Knative, is auto scaling.
Which means that
you as a developer
can write your
application and be
able to respond to
unpredictable usage patterns.
Whether it's a disaster
that suddenly creates
lots more demand
on your service,
or whether Justin Bieber
tweeted about some jeans
and your marketing application
has to respond to some service
much more--
or be able to scale much
larger audience of visitors.
What it also means that
Cloud Run manages your code
and configuration as unit.
The benefit of that is
that you have at all point
the ability to go back
to the last known state.
So it's not just the
code that was compiled
that's a certain version plus
a different configuration
and suddenly you have to
change the differences,
it's a unit, that
snapshot whenever
you apply a change to a service
that treats them together.
The other thing is that
Cloud Run underneath--
Cloud Run on GKE underneath is
using Istio, a very powerful
mesh service, that in order to
make that accessible to you,
we expose a very easy
to reason about object
model that allows you to
deal with things like routes
management or observability
around metrics
that you want to capture.
So in a situation of a-- a very
common situation, for example,
when you come to a
conference like this,
you get excited about
particularly technology,
you deploy your
application, it runs now.
You have users, great.
And now you say, I
want to run a change--
I mean, if it was me, I would
probably have a bug in there
so I have to fix it, but
you write a perfect code,
so no problem there.
You want to make a change,
but you have active users,
so how do you do this?
So the ability to manage Istio
underneath and manage those
routes reliably allows you to
support things like blue-green
deployment where you have a
new version of application
or experiments which you
can actually start sending
incrementally larger number of--
percentage of traffic
to this new version.
And on top of this also, Cloud
Run on GKE is also plugable.
What that means is
that it connects
very well with a series of
native services offered by GCP.
Cloud Run or Stackdriver,
whatever it may be--
and Donna has listed a
few other ones there.
But it also is extendable
by our partners,
and there's number
of them out there.
The ones I want to highlight
here is GitLab and Datadog.
If you've been in
developer space,
you probably are aware
of those companies.
DONNA MALAYERI: All right,
so enough with slides.
Are you all ready for demos?
You don't seem very excited.
Are you ready for demos?
[APPLAUSE]
There we go.
All right, so for our
first set of demos,
we're going to show you how
you can have easy request-based
activation and scale on demand.
For this I'm going to invite
Mike Mommsen from Airbus
Aerial.
He's going to talk
about how Airbus
is using Cloud Run on GKE.
MIKE MOMMSEN: Hi, guys.
I'm Mike.
That's a photo of me
with shorter hair.
So I'm a dev--
yeah, so-- yeah, like I
work as a back end dev.
I'm going to show the way that
we can use Cloud Run to make
our system simpler.
So here we go.
So like who are we?
Our goal is to be your
one-stop shop for all
your spatial data needs.
So we have satellite data
from our set of satellites.
We have a very massive
set of satellites,
we can get you satellite data
each day down 50-centimeter.
It's fantastic data.
We also have manned, which
we're calling airborne here.
And when you go and
you see a map online
and they claim it's satellite,
it's almost always manned.
And then we also have drone.
Drone's great for 3D models
or a very close-up inspection.
So we have all
this together, all
on a web browser-based system.
It's very simple if you're
not a GIS expert to use.
We can also bring in data
from our clients or data
that's different than this.
So we have it all together,
and one thing we've been--
so one of the use
cases that's been great
for us for helping
our clients has
been like all these
natural disasters.
So I actually was in
this room yesterday.
I saw a talk by a
guy from Mayday.ai,
and he said that
70% of the US is
at risk for a natural disaster.
So there are the fires
out here, there's
the floods in the Midwest,
and there's the hurricanes
out east.
When we have a storm
like that, no one
knows what's happening
on the ground.
It's a total wreck, you
can't get through with cars.
So to have some sort
of data available
allows the first responders
to know what's going on.
So in this case, there was just
a little tropical depression
on the 7th and 8th, and
then all of a sudden it
became a huge storm on the 9th.
It crashed into Mexico Beach
on the 10th, and on the 11th
we had data inside our portal
for our clients to use.
So it's very impressive
how we can get data
from a satellite into our system
and in front of our clients
in a very quick fashion.
This is actually very
important for our clients.
If we have a client that's
an insurance company, if they
see that picture
right there, they
don't have to send someone out.
They can just cut checks.
And this is very
important to the people
that were in these homes.
They can start their
lives a lot quicker.
It also like saves a lot of
money for the insurance company
because they don't
need to send out
people which can
cost $6,000 to $8,000
just to send out
a single person.
So helps people in
real life, and it
does some good for people.
So I'm going to
show how we do this.
So this is our spatial
data processing pipeline.
So starting on the left we
have raw data coming in,
and all the way to the right
we have our web browser.
Each of those arrows is
a program run by someone
like me wrapped into
a Docker container
with lots of good code in an OS,
and then on top of that a ton
of YAML so we can send it
up to the Google Cloud.
I actually joke that
I'm a YAML programmer
at this point because I'm
sure most of my lines of code
are actually YAML, but that's
the way it has worked for us.
It's a pretty good system,
but as you can see,
it's pretty complicated.
I'll just walk you through what
happened with the satellite.
So that would be
at the bottom here.
If we get satellite data in--
these are crazy data sets.
They're 80,000 pixels
by 40,000 pixels.
And we don't have to
process one of them,
we have to process
tons of them at a time.
So it'll be lots
of them coming in.
And then we load those
into Google Cloud Storage,
and we have to process
those into images
that are things that our
map server can serve up
so our clients can see it.
So there's lots of steps to get
our data from our source all
the way to the browser.
It's not terrible, but like this
is the system we were using.
At the top, that's vector
data, so that would be
stuff like parcels and whatnot.
So I'm going to show
the way that we can
improve this with Cloud Run.
So this is replacing all
of the image processing.
We don't need all those
intermediary files
because we can
scale down and up.
Very simply, we can skip
all the pre-processing,
serve off of an individual file.
So we have one TIFF and
we can use that TIFF
for all of our machine
learning, or we
can use that for all of
our spectral analysis,
and we can use that
for our map server.
So this makes our
data lot simpler.
Like, this is the way
that we think of our data.
It's a satellite
capture, we have
one file we store on
Google Cloud Storage,
and from there we can do all the
things we need to do with it.
This is very easy for us to
implement because we already
have everything as
Docker, so we can just
basically send that Docker image
up that Cloud Run and it works.
If we do want to try
out a new deployment,
we can do a blue-green,
so that's fantastic.
So, I mean, this
is a lot simpler
than that previous slide,
and I like it a lot.
MARK CHMARNY: Show us.
MIKE MOMMSEN: I'm
going to show you guys.
All right, so this is
a demo of that map tile
that I was describing.
So this is actually
running on Cloud Run.
And you saw those tiles
as they were loading.
Each one of those
tiles is a request that
goes to the Cloud Run server.
That Cloud Run server
sends a request to GCS.
And then it gets the data back
and then it recompiles it,
and it makes a tile
that we can see.
MARK CHMARNY: Donna
has a question.
DONNA MALAYERI: So this
might be good for you
because you're a
geospatial engineer,
but I can't see anything.
Can you please
enlarge and enhance?
MIKE MOMMSEN: So
this isn't "CSI,"
so we can't do the enhancing.
But--
MARK CHMARNY: Real-time?
No.
[LAUGHS]
MIKE MOMMSEN: But
actually, because we
didn't have to
pre-process the image
and we could serve
straight off that TIFF,
that TIFF has a lot
more colors in it,
and we have to reduce
the amount of colors
that go to the browser.
So because we didn't
have to pre-process it,
we can actually change the
way that we show the colors.
So this is that same image
that I was showing over here,
but we did a stretch to it.
So previously, if we would
have messed up the stretch,
and this does
happen, we would've
had a dark image
or a light image.
But now we can expose
to our front end
or to our clients' ability
to change the way that they
view the image.
So I can get in here
and I can actually
make this image look way worse.
So rather than doing a stretch
that goes between 2% and 98%,
I'll go from 2% to 70%.
And it's washed out
and looks terrible.
But it shows that we can
do on-the-fly processing,
and it's going to
change the way that we
can use our whole spatial
data processing pipeline.
And I'm very excited to
take this and apply it
to all the other areas that
you saw in that previous slide.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
DONNA MALAYERI: Awesome.
Thanks, Mike.
What I really like
about this demo
is that you didn't have to--
you can move away
from batch processing,
but you also don't have to
design for peak capacity,
because you can't really
plan for a natural disaster.
And until-- if you're not using
something like serverless,
you would have to provision
a lot of extra machines.
But here, when customers
want this data, this image
data on demand, you
can do the scaling,
and that's really the power of
having a serverless developer
experience.
So if we go back to
the slides, all right.
So Mark, in this case,
Mike had a container image.
Can you show us what happens
if you only have source?
MARK CHMARNY: Good.
I guess we--
I'm going to do a quick
overview here maybe first.
Can you go back to
slides for a second?
So I can do the demo
in a second here,
but I want to just kind
of walk you through.
So a lot of times we talked
about developers just wanting
to write code.
So in kind of a
GitOps-like setup or use
case, what that means is the
developers are committing
their code on an ongoing
basis into code repository,
and there are a series of
unit tests on their machines
and there are integration
tests that they're running
against the code repositories,
so whenever a new commit comes
in, it's executing.
But sooner or later,
the operator-- sorry,
the release manager will
come in and say, OK, I'm
ready to make a new cat and
deploy a new deployment.
So they will come in, they
will create a trigger in--
what we're going to show
here is the integration
of Cloud Build, which is another
hosted offering from Google
that's managing
the build process.
We're going to create a
trigger in there that's
going to go through
the series of steps
and deploy a new
image to Cloud Run.
So 100% transparently,
no user involved.
All right, let's switch back.
So what I have here is a clearly
for demo design application.
Unless you're in a prime
number-calculating business--
and who wouldn't
want to be in that?
That's kind of all it does.
You give it a number
and it calculates--
I don't know, let's do
something different.
Great.
So we get a number.
It's really not-- the
application is really not
important here, please
don't focus on that.
What's interesting here,
a couple of things.
First of all, we use this
also as a REST service.
So you can use it to test
the scalability use cases,
because you can pass
a larger number, which
will consume more CPU, but
also not something we're
going to do today.
The part I want to
focus on is over here.
What do we have is
for demo purposes,
we're injecting the
release tag that
was a signed by the release
manager in the repository
so that we can-- when this
entire application travels
through the pipeline
I showed you
before, we can actually see it.
So let's take a look
at this application.
This application-- again,
the application purpose
is really not relevant.
What we're going to focus on
is the release manager process.
There was 46
releases, you can see
we've been busy testing this.
So I asked the
release manager, going
to just create a new release.
And you know what?
I mean, let's call
this something like a--
DONNA MALAYERI: Next Demo.
MARK CHMARNY: Next Demo.
That's a great idea.
And Next Demo.
And because this is
demo, hopefully you
do better release notes than I
do in your production system.
And when we fire
this, what actually
is happening here
is that Cloud Run--
sorry, Cloud Build
automatically notices this.
So let's go kind of
deeper into this process.
What we have here is
information about the status
of that particular build,
including the repository
that it came from,
but it also has
a trigger that we can
kind of interrogate.
So what happens here is
the trigger's set up,
it indicates where
the repository
was-- so in this case it was
the GitHub repo that we went to.
Had some name that you
want to be able to use.
There's two different
ways you can trigger it.
So you can triggered
on a branch created
for QA/QC kind of
purposes, but in this case,
we went with a tag.
And the tag has a regex-- in
this case, release-v. Anything
after that, whenever Cloud
Build sees one of the stacks,
it will build the
entire process.
And there is a
configuration file,
but let's go over here quickly--
oh.
History.
Let's take a look at this.
So this build configuration
has number of steps,
and those are defined by you.
So you can build simple
only test, you can run--
build process and
push a repository.
But what we're doing in here is
we're capping the entire source
code, we're running a
test, we're creating--
building an image, publishing
that image to the repository,
GC image repository.
We're creating a
manifest in order
so we can inject
that environment
variable and other
configurations
that you need and deploy it.
And obviously there is a log
file you can access this.
So hopefully, if everything
worked correctly,
we can come in here, refresh it,
and you see my next demo label.
This happens transactionally.
So the request that
were being served
by the previous
version of release
are being completed
before a new one is
being sent to the user in
response to a HTTP request.
DONNA MALAYERI: All right.
Mark, I think you
should make this better.
So I noticed that when you
are in the Cloud Build UI,
you are refreshing to see what
the status is .Can you have
this trigger?
MARK CHMARNY: Yes.
So as part of our
demo again, we're
going to do kind of
an add-on process.
We're going to go in and use
one of the features of Cloud
Build which publishes build
status changes into it
pub/sub topic.
Pub/sub up is the
globally-distributed,
simple-to-use, elastic message
queue service offered by GCP.
And so there is--
whenever you have a Cloud
Build in your
project configured,
it will automatically
create that topic for you,
so you don't have to
do anything there.
What we're going
to do is we going
to create a very simple
subscription that
will watch for
events on this topic
and send them to an image.
Sorry, to a notification service
that will relay them to Slack.
If everything works OK, we'll
see this whole thing work
automatically.
So let's take a
look quickly at a--
we can close this--
at a simple notification
service that we're
going to deploy in here.
So this notification service,
among many other things,
is a Go application, but the
two things to focus on here
is it has a handler.
So we received a push
from it pub/sub topic,
and really, it does
many different things,
but on the end of the
day, it just really
extracts the notification that
was there-- so strongly-typed
object.
In the Node.js,
you might get away
by simply taking this
and sending to-- or any
other dynamic language.
And then it sends
it to a sender that
decorates it with
a beautiful Slack
message with icons
and everything
and shoots it over to--
on the very end to Slack.
Again, this is not as important.
So let's go-- where are we?
Let's go to command line.
And what we're going
to do here, this
is very narrowly command
line, so let me break it down.
We're going to
deploy the service.
First of all we're
going to G Cloud, which
is a CLI that you already come
in very familiar with if you're
using anything on GCP.
We're going to use
the run service,
and we're going to
deploy an application.
I'm calling very fancy
pub/sub notifications
or something like that.
The two things that we're going
to provide is an image path.
Now most of the demos you have
seen for ease of demonstration
so far, we're using something
like GCR, name of the project,
and name of the image, which
is great, it will work.
Except it's very
unpredictable, because what
is the latest image
today might not
be the latest
image tomorrow when
your application scales down.
So I'm going to use a SHA
that is specific to the image,
so it is very unique.
Cloud Build has an ability to
generate consistent predictable
images, so you can
guarantee that that image is
going to be the same even if
you reproduce that image over
and over.
So thankfully I'm not
going to have to type it
because it's a very long SHA.
The other thing I'm going
to provide in here-- again,
in a lot of demos we just
simply run some command
and it deploys it,
but in the real world,
you have some configurations.
So I'm populating some--
a few information in here.
So let's run this.
DONNA MALAYERI: So let me
make sure I understand this.
You wrote your own
custom code that
listens on a pub/sub topic,
and it posts to Slack
and this is what you're
deploying right now?
MARK CHMARNY: Yes.
So first of all if you
notice-- hopefully you notice,
because there a lot of work went
into this, deployment was fast.
Like I just run it and the
entire image from GCR deployed.
In fact, if we are
hit at some with--
my application now with some
traffic, that same performance
will be true for every
single new instance
of the application.
That is pretty awesome.
But the one thing
that we got here--
two things we got here
that we really care about
is a specific revision name of
the instance that we pushed.
Where remember to the
example I was talking about
before where you can come
back and say, you know what?
The new deployment I just did?
Not good.
Some tests did not work.
Let's go back to last
previous known state.
You can list those
states and say
go and make this one active.
But the other thing more
importantly-- what we got here
is a URL.
My instance is automatically
configured with a custom domain
and with SSL certificates,
so everything is working.
And what are we going to do now?
Hopefully you can see this.
We're going to create the
pub/sub back to G Cloud.
pubsub, subscription,
create, and everything
has to have a nice, long name.
So this is mine.
And two things that we
need to care about here.
One is we defined the topic.
Remember I told you that
Cloud Build automatically
creates a topic for you,
so this is constant name.
You can always
use it and there's
one of those in your project.
And the other thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
define push endpoint.
Pub/sub can work either
as a pool when you go out
and attach a client
and get events,
or it can work as a push.
So in this case,
we're using a push.
Whenever there is a new top--
a new message on a topic,
a subscription will be
created that will push that
to our service.
The other thing I'm doing
here that's worth noting is,
because I don't just--
I don't want you to
start sending events
to my notification
service in Slack,
I'm sharing a token
between both of those
that allow me to make sure
that only known publishers can
go for it.
So let's run this.
DONNA MALAYERI: So
basically this pub/sub topic
is what's creating the
connection between Cloud
Build and our Cloud Run
service that we just deployed.
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
So now we have our--
we have our image published--
service published,
we have our
subscription created.
So let's go back to
the browser, maxprime,
and we're going to
create a new release.
You've seen this already
before, so nothing new in here.
I can't type, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Duplicate name.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the release
number's [INAUDIBLE]..
MARK CHMARNY: I don't think it
really matters for the demo,
but let's go with 4.
How's that?
Better?
New One.
The name is not relevant
for this over here.
The release number is the
only thing that matters.
So we're going to publish this.
And don't worry, I'm not going
to make you go all the way back
to Cloud Build status so watch
this exciting progress going.
We're going to go
quickly to Slack.
I'm using the Knative
public channels.
So if you working on Knative
or are interested in a project,
you can always join us.
But I think you
will notice here is
that we've automatically
have published this saying,
hey, I'm working.
So what happened is that Cloud
Build said, I've copied--
I'm starting to work on this.
I went in, I copied--
I published a new
status called Working,
and that status
traveled through pub/sub
all the way to our simple
notification service
that really just
decorates nice messages
and sends them to Slack
and Slack displays this.
The other thing that we have
is where we link directly
to that build process.
So hopefully by then
we should be getting
pretty close to being done.
Where are we right now?
We are on step 1 still.
So this will run through
the exact same process.
And then eventually
we'll get to the point
where we have here, which will
publish a "hey, I succeeded."
You can customize this
the way you want it.
There's nothing
fancy in here, it's
just what we're showing
is that you can wire that
to a very simple web
hooks or services that
are connected together.
Do we want to wait
for this to finish?
How close are we?
There, we're done.
Let's see if we have
our final status.
Success!
DONNA MALAYERI: Yay.
MARK CHMARNY: I usually get
a clap for this, but OK.
[APPLAUSE]
DONNA MALAYERI: So
the interesting thing
is that this
application that listens
for these pub/sub topics
and publishes is glue.
And it's this glue that
is typically written,
and it functions as a
service on a hosted, say,
Google Cloud functions.
But here with Cloud Run, you
can run that glue code really
easily in your own GKE cluster.
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
So can we change the slides?
Yeah.
So this is just a very quick
summary of what we've done.
You've seen the first
one already there.
Pub/sub topic is
being configured
with this new
subscription-- you can have
any number of subscriptions.
So we have clients listening
and pushing and all that.
We've deployed a service, and
the service went to Slack.
There is a number
of CI/CD companies.
In fact, if you come to any of
the other Cloud Run services,
you will see, for example,
some of our partners
integrating with this.
So you might not,
for example, say
Cloud Build is not what I like.
I like, I don't know,
Jenkin X or I like GitLab.
Those partners have
active integrations
with Cloud Run on GKE.
All right.
The other thing that
often happens is--
like in all the
demos, because demos
need to be simple to show
during the conferences,
we often deal with
this use case where
there is one service, very
simple UI, something--
because you have to illustrate.
But in the real world,
you have a situation
where you have to
combine things together.
So hopefully you're
kind of following
like a 12-factor application
development model
or you have a series
of microservices
that you stitch together.
Cloud Run, in
addition to what I'm
going to show you, also
introduce-- like I said,
introduces a service mesh.
So you can bind those services
in much more usable manner.
The example I like to say
is that it's very simple
to manage three microservices.
When you get to 10, 20,
100, you can't rely just
on your own-- hey,
I know or I'm going
to remember the URL
over there or something
like that, because they just
connect together, right?
So what we're
going to do here is
we're going to build our little
more real world solution.
I'm going to deploy
a service that it's
doing nothing else, just
exposing a REST API for a user
to request a service
to identify a logo.
So we're going to send
a bunch of images,
and it will tell us what logo
is in that particular image.
It's using behind-the-scene
Vision API,
which is part of our ML stack.
You can use anything else.
What we are going
to do then is we
going to come in and say, OK,
great, Vision API uses credits.
I don't want the entire
world to use my credits.
So I'm going to front this
application with a simple OAuth
application which is going
to use Google OAuth service,
and I'll expose a
nice visual UI to it.
So no longer cURL commands, but
we're going to use a simple UI.
I built this all
myself, so don't expect
any beautiful graphics there.
But if you were really
kind of paying attention,
you quickly realize that
there is nothing stopping
somebody continue doing this.
Now we have number
of microservices,
and if you use some
of our other services,
we have that situation
where everything
is exposed to the internet.
So in this case on
Cloud Run, we provide
a way is to deal with that.
So let's switch back
to a command line and--
sorry, to demo.
The command line?
Can you switch to a specific
window on my machine?
All right.
So what are we going
to do here, I have--
how big is this?
Is this big enough?
I don't think I can go
any bigger than this.
DONNA MALAYERI:
Can people see it?
MARK CHMARNY: So we're
running here is-- we've
executed a simple cURL comment.
Let's see what the
image looks like.
DONNA MALAYERI: So here you're
just-- this is the first slide
that you just showed, right?
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
We're going-- sorry.
I've walked you through
the entire process,
we're going to go back
and kind of navigate.
You and I know this is
Kubernetes, but for a machine,
yeah, I'm not sure what
they know what it is.
So what we just invoked here
is this service in a step 1
where we directly got
the result from a Vision
API that was managed by the
REST service that we exposed.
By the way, the Vision API
exposes all other attributes
that I'm kind of just hiding
and disregarding in here,
but I'm just bringing the one
for demonstration purposes.
So let's do this.
So let's go in now and take a
look at the demo application.
So kdemo.
Simple application,
and like I told you,
no beautiful graphics there.
But what it allows us to do is
come in here and authenticate--
I'm going to use my
personal one for this.
Is this visible?
Yeah.
So what it allows
us to do is ask
the very same thing in a
much more user-friendly way.
So you can click the
images, populate--
you can paste your own.
Again, the application
doesn't really matter.
So we have our simple UI that
forces users to authenticate
so we know who is running.
Great, except now,
still no bueno, right?
I can continue running this
directly against the back end
service.
So let's come to a cloud UI.
Oh, that's the wrong window.
DONNA MALAYERI: So
basically you added a UI
and you got a lot of
people to sign in,
but you didn't protect the
service so people can still
get to it directly.
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
So I'm looking at the
Cloud Run UI here.
You can do the same thing
in a command line, but for--
I've noticed that we don't
show much of the Cloud Run UI
in demo, so this is
my mission for today.
The other thing you
will notice here
that I have mix and
match of services.
You will see some things
that running Cloud Run on GKE
in a particular cluster
called next, because I
can't be creative anymore.
Or they're running on
the managed service--
the same interface, the
same developer experience,
the same operational experience
that you've done before.
So let's go into our klogo
service that's on next.
You see the image that we
publish and everything else,
but one of the things
we can do in here,
we can actually come
in and very easily--
you can do this from a
command line, by the way, too.
We can change this to internal.
Two things will happen.
Let's do no longer jQuery
because it'll be easy.
Let's do more verbose.
cURL give us a lot of
things, but the one thing
I really care about is
here, our HTTP status.
By the way, did
you notice HTTP2?
Huh?
It upgraded automatically.
The other thing that we see here
is the status for my service
is now 404.
It's not that we
have protected this,
we have made it not visible.
So it's only accessible
in a cluster local.
Well let's see if our
UI continues to run,
if I can only find the
demo here-- there we go.
Let's make a new one.
Droid.
There it is.
That was it.
So let's switch
the slides maybe.
Quickly.
I know it was a
lot moving parts,
so I'm going to
bring a slide here
that kind of helps
us understand.
So what we've done, and
we've created services--
I actually added behind
the scene another one
because I don't
want you to continue
abusing my servers by running
the URL multiple times.
So I'm adding a
user service that's
using a Firestore for
persistence of data.
Very scalable data
service, very easy to use.
And it does metering.
So I think I have like 100
queries per user per day.
So if you are being
very diligent,
it will probably block
you there eventually.
But the other thing we've
done is very quickly
made both of those
backing services
that don't need to be
exposed externally directly.
We made them cluster local.
Fancy term for saying they
don't have an external URL,
but it do have a URL that can
be discovered by my front UI
and connect to them.
That's it.
DONNA MALAYERI: Yeah, so
basically what you can see here
is this is a more realistic
application where you actually
have multiple
microservices, you're
protecting your
services, and you're
making sure that things
are production-ready.
Because there's a big gap
between what works in demos
and what works in
production, but we
have things available
for both of you--
for both of those
scenarios for you.
So what we showed you was the
developer experience for Cloud
Run on GKE, and you saw when
Mark showed the Services
tab in Cloud Run, it's actually
the same developer experience.
There are just different
configuration options
that are available
in each environment.
And you can mix and match.
You could decide, well,
I have a cluster already,
I'm going to use
the spare capacity
to do part of my workload.
I'm going to put some of
it on hosted Cloud Run.
You could change your mind
later and move it back,
it's extremely easy.
And because it's all
powered by Knative,
you're not using
a particular API
that may not be available
in some other environment
that you're running.
So your workload is portable.
There's another thing that's
portable, though, that I think
it's really important to know.
It is your skills as a
developer or as the tech person.
We have a limited amount of
time to learn some new framework
and some new stack,
and it's hard to know
what thing to learn
that's actually
going to be durable,
that's going
to be useful in
multiple environments.
And this is one of the things
that Knative gives you.
Because it's a standard,
consistent, developer-friendly
API that is available
on multiple vendors,
not just Google
Cloud, you can know
that the things that you've
learned, you can use elsewhere.
So multiple teams working
in the same company
can have a consistent
developer experience.
So thank you very much.
If you want to learn more, you
can go to cloud.google.com/run.
The Knative website is also
available now at knative.dev,
and you can also ask us
questions on Twitter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]